C Roland warboys chair of miter District
Council and I will be chairing the
meeting
today may I first of all remind you of
some demestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs do not re-enter the building until
you are told it is safe to do
so please switch off all mobile phones
or turn them to silent which reminds me
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you'll be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
can I remind members to speak clearly
into the microphones and to not put
their papers over the microphones can I
move to the agenda
please uh apologies for
absence thank you chair I've received
apologies for absence from counc
Bradbury overett Ross Piper and
Stringer are there any Declarations of
Interest none
I uh item MC 2317 to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on 21st of
September
2023 for accuracy
only are there any issues with
accuracy could I have a proposal
please Council maton or is yes sorry
sorry chair yeah I've I've um posted two
two minor um textual changes which the
the officers have got um to to
clarify the the
minutes have we got those um chair yeah
we have received those and they the
minutes have been amended so the
corrected version are in front of you
now and have been tabled
are there any further issues with
accuracy could I have a proposal
please uh Council eurn I you second
Council
maton uh I'll take the vote by show of
hands please all those in
favor that's Carri that is
carried
um
uh item MC 2318
chairs items I refer you to paper mc23
18 for noting I would also like to take
this opportunity of thanking all the
services Council staff volunteers parish
councils and District councils who
responded to the calamitous flooding
last Friday special thanks to Farmers
and tractor drivers particularly in
deham who help rescue stranded motorists
and F children through flood water our
public realm have been prompt to respond
respond collecting damaged carpets and
other items and many positive comments
have been receiv received from grateful
residents many families are going to
need long-term support as their homes
will take several months to dry
out and this is a personal thank you to
Peter a farm worker in thunderson who
came to my wife's rescue as she was
marooned at the foot of Prior Road in
palra lessons need to be learned as
these one in a 100 years events appear
to be happening more frequently and we
have a duty to building resilience into
our
communities on Friday I due to attend
the launch of the poppy peel in Stow
Market in 1921 herle noticed French
widows selling silk poppies to rise
money for disabled ex servicemen the
poppy was subsequently adopted as a
symbol of remembrance for the first
World War War the war to end
Wars I'm sure we're all too aware of the
horrific events in the Middle East we
have Jewish and Muslim families in our
communities who will be grieving for
lost ones and praying for Mission
relatives praying perhaps for an end to
this cycle of violence that appears to
have no end we must be vigilant against
both anti-Semitism and
islamophobia as grief may turn into
anger and hatred as people become
vulnerable to ruthless and unscrupulous
agents neither must we forget it is now
day
610 of the brutal and unprovoked Russian
invasion of Ukraine and we must look to
the ongoing needs of ukrainians in our
communities who are also grieving and
praying for their loved
ones finally before I move to the next
item I would like to thank ifte Ali on
behalf of the council for all the help
and support he has given over the past
year I would like to wish him well in
his retirement
[Applause]
thank thank
you I would like to invite Council
Millan to present his update
please thank you chair um last weekend's
floods were the worst mids suffk has
experienced for many years and it's been
a deeply distressing time for many of
our residents and businesses who have
seen property damaged and lives
disrupted a huge cleanup is now well
underway and I know we will all continue
to do all we can to support residents
businesses and communities during this
recovery period additional Council staff
have been deployed in the worst affected
areas to assist with the cleanup and to
help find temporary accommodation for
affected residents in areas like deham
Stow Market needer market and others
as the chairman has said drying out
properties and getting chair repairs
done will take time but we are committed
to supporting residents and helping
communities to
recover we welcome the government's
announcement of recovery funding and
we'll work with the County Council and
other agencies to secure this and make
sure it reaches those in need I do want
to say a thank you a huge thank you to
everyone who was there for our
communities at the weekend to our
emergency services to our Council staff
who responded to to the flooding to
counselors who are out in your
communities over the weekend doing
outstanding work identifying issues and
taking
action and to our town and Parish
councils and the local volunteers who
help their neighbors family and friends
particular thanks to the farmers who
helped to Ferry children through flood
water and to rescue
motorists um and again to the the deham
Leisure Center staff Who provided an
overnight rest center for those forced
from their homes also thanks to the
teachers and School staff who ensured
the safety of
children there will inevitably be many
more that I've missed but thank you to
everyone it was a difficult weekend
there is still a lot of work to do but
we should recognize the Fantastic show
of community Spirit across mid
saach I'd like to also remind everyone
that there's still time to have your say
on the council's future Direction and
and priorities we have outlined the the
council's or the the administration's
draft priorities but we want feedback
from the community are these priorities
right what else could we do and what
have we missed the survey is live until
the 15th of November and details can be
found on the website and I hope members
will encourage people to take part
posters and postcards have also been
created where you can which you can
share with your communities and I know
some councilors have asked for paper
copies of the survey and we do have
those here tonight so please do collect
a few on your way out if you want to use
those we're pleased to have partnered
with groundwork East to deliver free
impartial expert advice to help
businesses and organizations save energy
reduce their emissions and establish
tailored decarbonization plans and this
new net zero business advice service
will provide free support to help
businesses the voluntary sector and
other organ organizations to understand
their greenhouse gas emissions set a
plan to reduce them and then access
grant funding to implement carbon
reduction actions and more information
about this is found on our
website uh safer suff renters this is a
new initiative which aims to improve
life for landlords and tenants in the
private rented sector we're joining
forces with suff other district and
burough councils to deliver this ground
breaking groundbreaking Project SAFE for
suffer renters is designed to create a
better understanding of the pressures
and problems in the sector and to
improve standards particularly in the
worst private rented homes in the area
and to achieve this the project team
will consult widely with tenants
landlords and stakeholders in the in the
county there is a conference taking
place at the University of suffk in IPS
on the 3rd of November and that's free
for all landlords to attend again
details are available on our website and
there will be similar conferences for
tenants and stakeholders and those will
follow lastly members will recall the
amendment to the last budget which was
agreed unanimously to set aside 22
million for insulation and other Home
energy saving measures now officers have
been working hard to design this scheme
and I'm pleased to say that we'll be
launching this init this initiative
called cozy homes next month and my
colleague councelor winch has been
working with the officers and will
provide full details ahead of the
launch uh I said lastly I meant just
before lastly finally just to say that
um Council olle Walters is now going to
take on the role of lead member for
waste and recycling in the
administration thank
you are there any questions please for
clarification um councilor
winch
I hear that one of suffix MPS has been
criticizing mids suffk planning in
relation to the floods um could you give
some clarification of that
please Council thank you chair um yes
that was somewhat disappointing
um I suppose I'd like to say first that
our our planning staff do a brilliant
job in often quite challenging
circumstances um and as a broad point we
had an independent assessment of that
service uh less than two years ago
through a peer Challenge and the review
team considered it very well managed and
with some very efficient processes um
they also said we're performing well
against all the national indicators um
on the issue of flooding specifically um
our planners have to operate within the
framework that the government sets and
it wasn't until 2021 that the government
took a more responsible approach to flu
plal flooding that is running flooding
from Heavy Rain through the national
policy planning framework and I think
it's it's really wrong to kind of blame
our planners for what happened over
recent days you know we do want a kind
of positive and collaborative approach
with with across the public sector
including our MPS uh instead of people
pointing fingers at us thank
you Council
W thank you chair um first I'd like to
second Council melon's huge thank you to
our officers and staff and others for
their flood response but um I have a
question for councelor melon regarding
matters covered in section three of his
report on Net Zero advice and the
partnering with groundwork East a
community facility in my ward the condom
Center has put a lot of time effort and
grant money into reducing their carbon
footprint by almost 80% investing in
ground Source heating LED lighting and
solar PV batteries it's an Exemplar
scheme but they now find themselves
having to renew their accrediation at a
cost of over 800 including unrecoverable
vat and that accreditation lasts for
only three years before a need to renew
yet again and clearly the lengthy
lifetime of this project these costs
will accumulate significantly so please
could Council melan Lea with officers
and groundwork East to investigate
whether there's any external funding
available to cover these ongoing
accreditation costs and also to
establish whether there's any way that
the accredit could last for a longer
period than just three years thank
you yeah thank you I'm very pleased to
hear about this initiative in codam and
it sounds like they're doing exactly the
right things um the ground initiative on
uh business support is entirely separate
to the the carbon Charter which is the
other measure that they are involved in
which I think is what you're referring
to um I will ask staff to have a look
into to that to see whether the um the
um uh the the review periods for that
could be lengthened because it sounds
like three years is not long enough for
that sort of organization thank
you thank you Council Hicks you have a
question yeah thank you very much a
roundabout question if I may um can I
just add agree with Council men and
thank the uh the the the public for what
they did at times of of real what was
for many a real time of emergency and I
just wanted to really actually just pay
credit to it's dangerous mentioning
names but I just want to pay credit to
the team at mids suffer to Mark M who I
have found has been incredibly
responsive on every email within seconds
despite the fact he's being probably
bombarded by every counselor and also to
Brad Jones because I thought the
communications to counselors through the
whole process was really great came
forward very quickly uh would as a
question Council melan agree that it's
really important that anyone that has
been flooded goes straight on to either
mids suffer or suff County Council
reports in-house flooding so we can
build a whole picture very quickly so
that we can take advantage of the
government grants that are coming
through um absolutely agree with that um
clearly the amount of grant funding that
might come suffs way is is contingent on
the number of properties that have been
affected so I would encourage all
members to uh make sure that people in
your Wards are
reporting uh flooded property es whether
it's businesses or homes uh through the
relevant channels through the district
or the County council's
website thank you are there any further
questions for
clarification none I I shall move
on uh questions by the public in order
accordance with Council
procedure I over oh beg you pardon uh to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with Council proced procedure
rules thank you chair none
received always read round to the bottom
of the question paper
should questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure
rules none received
chair questions by councils in
accordance with Council procedure
rules I refer to you to the question in
the cable
papers table papers I would now like to
invite Council Elkin to ask a question
thank you chair in July this Council
unanimously approved the motion to write
to the government in order to register
our opposition to the proposed Norwich
Tilbury pylon line and to call instead
for an integrated offshore approach a
letter was subsequently sent to the then
Secretary of State for energy security
and Net Zero the right honorable Grant
chaps and then to his successor in the
role the right honorable CLA coutino
with reference to this can I ask the
chair if he has received a respon
thank
you uh no
counselor elen no I have not received a
response
today do you have a second question yes
please thank
you as you have not received a response
from the relevant government Minister
can I ask what other steps we might be
able to take as a council to ask the
government and the National Grid to to
provide information on a strategic
offshore solution which incorporates all
the planned energy projects which would
cost less and minimize the impact on
local communities and the environment
thank
you
uh thank you counselor
um I am prepared I am quite happy to to
write to our local MPS to actually sort
of um see if this this question this
letter can actually be not just answered
but actually acknowledged we have
not received any acknowledgement that
they've actually had the
letter um my understanding is where we
are with regard to the uh pylons is that
we're waiting for a study by the
National Grid
ESO uh this was the progress on this was
last reported in August
2023 to say that they are waiting on a
government decision on funding the
continued development of offshore
coordination between certain offshore
wind farms and interconnectors is
made uh and then the national grido will
independently assess the different ways
the electricity can be
transported currently it is up to gb's
transmission
owners uh to work through the exact
specifications of required Network
infrastructure and consult with
communities and make DEC decisions on
what to
build
um
we that is a situation as I understand
it and we and I'll I'll go back to the
first bit we are waiting on a government
decision to fund in on funding the
continued
development
um I'm happy to sort of um ask for
letters to be sent to our local MPS to
see if they can sort of engender a
response from the SEC the current
Secretary of State for energy
um uh CLA
continue is that a satisfactory
answer uh thank
you MC
2319 uh overview and scrutiny committee
report I'd like to invite Council Casten
to introduce his report
thank you chair um it's a pleasure to um
to give you the OB and scrutiny um
committee report for July August and
September I'd like to thank all the all
the members all the substitutes my um
Vice chair and the officers for um all
the work they've done on that um there
is a there was an issue with it where I
tested um positive for coid for the
September meeting at the um at the last
minute and um councelor Mary McLaren
chaed the meeting for me so where it
says authors at the bottom of the report
councelor Mary McLaren from babber
should be on that list because she did
the um report on the September meeting
but um the reports for noting and I'm
quite happy to answer questions thank
you you're fully
recovered um are there any questions for
Council
Casten
no further questions um thank you chair
this uh thank uh councelor
hardigan I would like to ask the
counselor um was there any consideration
of the need for angland water to
reassess the adequacy of the sewage
system to accommodate new developments
and make proper provision for increased
load before occupation
well um this is the meeting that I
wasn't present at um but um I believe
there was um there was a lot of
discussion um along those lines that was
um there is an issue as a planning
Authority that um it's our job to make
sure that there's the infrastructure to
take um the um the waste that um our new
um developments produce the um there is
a um the suffer County Council um
flood risk um scrutiny committee
subcommittee um did um Lobby the
government over a section in the um
water management act previously um which
was to do with the amount of water
that's um a flood water that goes into
the sewage system which obviously
overloads the um the the natural Capac
the normal capacity of the sewers and
this was discussed in this meeting um if
that helps you but I can um I can get
you a better reply to that but
unfortunately that was the one meeting
that I wasn't present at thank
you are there any further
questions right I would just like to
point out that report is for no in
only uh item 10 MC 2320 solar and low
carbon energy position statement I'd
like i' like to invite Council melan to
introduce paper MC
2320 and to move the recommendation in
the
report thank you chair um I'm presenting
this item on behalf of my colleague
councelor Stringer who is having a
well-deserved Break um this position
statement on solar and low carbon energy
is very timely uh members I'm sure are
very aware of the several planning
applications for solar Farms that our
planning committee have had to
deliberate on over the last few months
can I pay tribute to members of the
committee for their hard work they've
put in and their diligence in making
these difficult decisions there has been
a lot of local attention and feelings
have occasionally Run
High the position statement that I'm
presenting today seeks to clarify the
council's position as far as we are able
to and I hope that it does make it clear
for communities that are affected by
these
developments paragraph 4.6 in the report
sums up the situation very
well it says this addressing climate
change is vital protecting agricultural
land is important safeguarding landscape
value is essential working with our
communities is a key strategic priority
and balancing all these things is
difficult and I think that paragraph
sums up the Dilemma we often and find
ourselves
in ideally we would have a supplementary
planning document covering this issue
and we will have one eventually Under
The Joint local plan this is one of the
nine spds that officers are working on
but this position statement is what we
can do now and it focuses on three key
issues the loss of the best and most
versatile Farmland the potential harm to
the landscape and the concerns and fears
being expressed by our community
but I do want to make it clear as an
Administration we are in favor of
renewable energy
production we cannot hope to meet the
Count's and the C's Net Zero aspirations
without a substantial increase in solar
wind and other
Renewables but we strongly encourage the
installation of solar panels on existing
and new
buildings but we recognize that this is
largely directed by national build
building
regulations it is frustrating that the
current planning framework does not
allow us to mandate solar panels or new
roofs yet we are unable to prevent them
being put on even our best
Farmland so I think this position
statement is a useful interim holding
position until we get a full SPD in due
course and I'm happy on that basis to
propose the recommendations 3.1 the
solar and low carbon energy position
statement set out at a appendix a be
adopted and published on the council's
website I would like to make a minor
amendment to a recommendation
3.2 and that's this that the director of
Planning and Building control in
consultation with the cabinet member for
planning and the chair of the planning
committee that's the additional sentence
be authorized to make any minor
amendments as necessary uh but that's my
proposal and I'm happy to ask for a
second
councilor M well than you thank you
chair I'm very happy to uh second that
proposal thank
you we'll now move to questions have we
got any questions
please councelor
Hingham thank you um
I'm um I'm happy to to vote for this but
would this have made any difference to
the last two controversial solar FS
planning committee has some seen how
grave and a
great so um I
think around that answer is is the
question of whether this is a material
consideration which would would play a
part in in in planning um this is a
material consideration um but it can't
set policy um and obviously decision
making starts from the development plan
which is why it's clear in there about
policy M lp25 from the local plan so I
think essentially what this document is
doing is is describing what the council
would like to see and what we'd expect
good developers to demonstrate um and
would' love to see them addressing those
points we did see some movement on those
uh those last two applications perhaps
not as much as we'd have liked to um but
I feel that this um this this statement
would contribute um to better decision
making in the future so yes I think it
probably could have made a
difference
um yes coun could
you I would like to know if this
statement was being prepared prior to
the last planning meeting particularly
concerning the Paul grave decision why
we weren't told that this was in Ying as
part of that process because I think it
would have been a great help to have had
this then or at least deferred the
decision of the PO grave application
until after this
document thank you thank you Council
Lawrence councilor M I'll attempt to
answer that um the this position
statement has been in progress for some
time in preparation this was the first
opportunity to bring it to full Council
um I understand that the power grave
decision was already deferred once um
the problem with deferring things
multiple times is that you end up in a
position where um we could be um we
could uh you know we could ask for a
non-determination and take it to appeal
so um I think the information here is is
only a collation of what's already out
there um I'm not sure that necessarily
it would have been um helpful to have it
in draft form in the public
domain Council
Manel um I I'd like to ask a question
that may be as a question for the
officers um if that's okay um uh now I
understand that this is an interim
statement uh before we get our our
supplementary planning guidance uh so I
would just like to ask if we have any um
can we have any sort of indication of
the timeline for the production of the
supplementary planning document thank
you can I ask the director please to
respond yes through you chair um thank
you if it would be okay I'll pick that
up with outside of the meeting it is on
the published local development scheme
just take me a few minutes too many to
pull that out and and identify what it
is of course at the next council meeting
um councilors will get a new local
development scheme and that will set out
the timetable for both um the Future
Part Two local plan but also the
creation of supplementary planning
documents there
thank you um in in giving clarification
to applicants residents um obviously
languages is crucial and um Council
referred to paragraph 4.6 where he said
addressing climate change is vital
protecting agricultural land is
important and safeguarding Landscape
value is essential so just in terms of
those three words vital important and
essential how how would he actually rank
those in priority in terms of the
clarification he's trying to put forward
thank
you yeah so this is um this is the uh
the problem of referring to to a
paragraph that someone else has written
um I I think it's very difficult to rank
those um in fact I looked at those and
thought I might have used slightly
different words but I think it does sum
up the essential problem um that we're
trying to struggle with
um I I would say if anything uh
addressing addressing climate change is
essential uh working with our
communities is the way we want to do
things um and too often in this area um
it's it feels like we are doing things
to a community rather than with them um
so I would certainly like to move toward
towards a position where we are working
much closer with Comm communities it
would be brilliant if we had some
Community uh solar initiatives coming
forward um and I think if people could
see local benefit for example reduced
price electricity um you know section
111 uh benefits coming out to the
community I think people would be much
more in favor of these things I hope
that's some kind of
answer thank you chair um well I welcome
this um after this is adopted which I'm
presuming it's going to be adopted by
council tonight um would you be able to
as a council Lobby central government
along with other local authorities for
changes that would allow us to have uh
the right kind of development where
solar panels are and not necessarily on
agricultural
land yes I think we will we have done
and we will continue to Lobby um I did
make a speech at the LGA a conference on
this particular issue back in July uh
which was um you know referenced in the
local press and and in the um and the
first magazine so yes I think it is an
emerging area of um kind of conflict um
I'm sure government is going to give
some attention to this because um
communities are um in some cases up in
arms about it let's be honest um and I
think people's understanding of the
balance between energy production and
food production is something which is um
still
developing councilor
hardingham because available connection
opportunities uh for solar farms and
indeed other large scale energy projects
um are really relatively few uh and far
between still at the moment it is
evident that there will be multiple
applications in these particular in a
location not related to the soil quality
for instance uh or the cropping ability
of the the Farmland
roundabout um it's important therefore
that the cumulative impact on
communities where multiple applications
are likely to be coming forward um
centered on these connection points can
be considered in uh in planning
decisions and um in in making decisions
about where solar Farms can go and many
there should be in any one location um
is this going to be a a part of an
SBD if and when it comes forward thank
you yeah I'll I'll get Tom to come in
with further clarification but as far as
I understand it the the cumula
cumulative effect only kind of comes in
as a material consideration once one
application has been approved and then
another application comes uh in the same
landscape area area but um Tom not if
you can provide some further
clarification on
that slly um sorry through you chair a
good question uh slightly complex um
situation ENT a key plank of of planning
the approach to planning is that each
application is determined on its merits
but clearly there are cumulative impacts
and that is something that we will have
to pick up and address within the
supplementary planning document the
extent to which we do so um I need to
look into and and speak to councilors
further on
that are there any further
questions CC
peny yes um as as we are to have solar
Farms would councelor melon agree that
we have an opportunity to provide um
models of best best practice uh perhaps
under planning
conditions does this um motion allow for
that or assist with
that um yes I think there is scope for
um a Forward Thinking developer to um
pilot uh best practice in this area um
and and that to my mind would mean very
early consultation with the community it
would mean identifying Community
benefits as I've talked about
previously and responding to community's
concerns about the impact on the
landscape um so I very much hope that we
will see something like that coming
forward I very much fear that some of
the applications coming towards us are
on the largest scale and they may be
beyond our um scope of determination I.E
they they will be
NPS um but we'll see what happens um it
will be great to see um some kind of
very Progressive um developments coming
forward in this
space you Council
Morgan good evening I would like to seek
reassurance for our communities within
Midsummer suffk that there is going to
be some kind of control upon these
energy companies and that it's not
simply just going to be a green light
for these
policies I think the uh what we set out
in the position statement is the limits
of uh our controls under the current
planning guidance and
rules uh what we've set out in there is
what we'd like to see developers do um I
think uh we
are we are in a difficult position where
um as I said previously we cannot
mandate solar panels on roofs which is
where we'd like to see them and we
cannot protect the most uh the best and
most versatile agricultural land it's
not a comfortable place to be
uh but this position statement seeks to
clarify things and to set out a
direction of
travel thank you are there any further
questions
councel um regarding nsips as you say
that I think there may be some more
coming up you know are we going to have
a position as as a Council on these ends
we might we not might not have overall
control of them but are we willing to
oppose them and uh stand against
them where we feel that
they're they're
inappropriate um I'll I'll ask uh the
director for clarification on this but
as far as understand it as when an insip
comes through we have the opportunity to
comment on
them yeah
through you chair um yes we would be a
consultee on any nationally significant
infrastructure projects and as such the
council would be in a position to um
would be able to State its position and
respond to those consultations
formally uh thank you chair yes I
wondered uh whether Central govern
government actually have an allocation
of solar Farmers per
District which covers the country does
this exist or
not I think the um the problem with that
is that Sunshine is unequally
distributed um as a Welshman you will
know that it uh you don't get quite so
much over there as we do here um that's
from my memory of working in Wales for a
year um so unfortunately as the sunniest
part of the country we do tend to be in
the firing line in terms of these
applications um so um as far as
understand it we're you know potentially
producing far more energy than suffer
needs already um but you know we are I
think described now as NP Central or the
energy Coast or whatever so you know
there's lots going on in suffk um but
it's um you know it feels sometimes like
we're taking one for the
country are there any further
questions
um as the questions have finished we'll
now move to the debate councils will
only be allowed to speak once for three
minutes and this will be
timed uh would like to councilor maton
thank you chair yes um I i' firstly like
to acknowledge um the the thanks that um
that councilor melon offered to the
committee um that is
appreciated um I'm a member of it of
course um but what I think the the value
of this statement has has been said it's
not not going to have huge Cutting Edge
as as a material consideration but it
will help the public more of the public
to understand what we do and what what
was quite heartening the end at the end
of a very long um debate on on solar
farm was that one of the one of the
objectives from the parish council
um said to me afterwards how much how
she impressed she had been with how hard
the whole committee had
worked on on that application and to get
the best of that we could out of it h
and so I think that if if more people
watch it on YouTube or sit here and
listen to it um and and this is the next
best thing to that so I welcome the
statement thank you Council Council
Manel thank you chair um now I I I do
welcome the sentiments of the position
statement but understand its limitations
as it's not a policy document um and uh
for our communities that have had to um
deal with the um solar farm applications
that we we've determined at planning
committee it is a very emotive subject
for them and we have as the committee we
have difficult decisions to make now
much of what is put into that position
statement are the sorts of things that
we've tried to be conditioning whe if
we've granted permission um and I think
what the statement is trying to do is
trying to encourage
developers that this is the sort of
thing that we've been doing when we've I
conditioned um permission um so why not
do it in the first place and make our
lives a little bit easier um so I think
um I think the sentiment of it is right
I think it perhaps needs a little bit
more clarity um as has been pointed out
by councelor Whitehead that what ises
essential and and vital mean what what
is it we're actually asking developers
to do we often say we want them to after
the I after the event after they've got
permission that they've got to have a
community liaison group wouldn't it be
wonderful if they did that beforehand
and that's really what we're asking them
so I would like to see a nice clear
statement at the bottom of the paragraph
about Community is we're expecting you
to Lea with the community before the
application gets determined then the
other um the other um criteria were the
to do with the
Landscaping uh again um at the recent um
both those recent um solar farm
applications we have asked the developer
to go back and and change the
Landscaping particularly along public
rights of way um and places where the
public are are are actually I think it's
more a case of that they don't like the
unknown they don't know what it's going
to be like um because what was there was
a carrot field or whatever and now it's
going to have a six foot plus hard deer
fence and a load of um steel um infrastr
you know solar panels behind it no one
really knows what that's going to be
like until we actually get one I I think
we we need a site visit to go and see
one once it's finished so we actually
truly understand what it is really like
to live adjacent to a solar farm um and
then there is this age-old question of
the um the quality of the farming land
so um I I think all of these things are
good things to put in the statement but
we just need to make it quite clear what
we are expecting um developers to do
when they submit an application um but I
welcome the sentiment and I'll be voting
for it um but I would like to tweak it
thank you
coun Council
kton thank you very much chair and um
you you won't be surprised to hear that
I don't think this goes far enough um
coming from Branford we've had so so
much um so many applications it's been a
really difficult time for the people of
Branford and the people trying to fight
this um it seems like this doesn't
actually change or help the position of
those residents but it does clarify
things and I think the more information
is better in this case but I would like
to see this SPD come through so we can
we can actually push developers to do
better where they um where they apply
and also refuse some it's um it it does
um strike me as the land quality thing
on on these it could create thousands
more tons of carbon on a
49.9 um
megawatt
installation um using decent quality
land taking that land out of production
and then importing from China or Russia
or other countries there some food that
we need it's um it makes a massive
difference even when we get down to um 3
a land that makes a massive difference
it's a huge amount of carbon extra
carbon the um Community solar projects I
think this Council should go for those
in a in a bigger way I think that's a
way to um do something that suits this
community because the um the biggest
thing about this is most of the power
generated from these solar Farms that
we're putting in mid suffk is going
north and south not not just north and
south and suffk Norfolk Tilbury and
we've got a load more pylons um proposed
that will mean we're even more in danger
of getting more solar why are we
producing the power on our fields to
supply other parts of the country it
just um it it
with also with this I'm I am really
disappointed that the council didn't
fight the appeal against the Enzo um
application it left um residents and
Parish Council completely on their own
to try and um fight that Enzo um
application and um it was a it was a
really stressful and difficult time for
people that aren't part of a council
it's um it put us in a really bad
position I'll just can I could I just
finish there's a huge amount of money to
be made by these Solar Development for
investment funds that we can ask for so
much more they can they can they can
give us so much more and the
applications we really need to be
pushing them for that if we can't stop
them and and I'm saying in un
unappropriate solar Farms I'm not
against solar farms in general but we
need to be pushing them more there's
millions and millions of pounds and
business rates for the council involved
there they can afford to do it thank you
thank you chair
sorry uh thanks very much Mr chairman um
yeah I'll will support this um this this
uh proposal but I think we need to be
realistic and it's been said by uh
councelor melan this actually carries
very little weight uh it carries very
little weight as a material
consideration for the planning committee
and because it hasn't been out for
public consultation so I would say
actually it's more of a desire or a wish
list rather than anything that actually
carries any substance and I think it's
really important that the council takes
a far more robust approach going forward
takes it positions itself far more
strongly because I think there is a real
risk here that the public need to think
about that by electing a green Council
there is a significant risk that we are
seen as a soft target for multiple solar
Farms across the district because they
are I think there is a risk r that
developers will think a green Council
opportunity for solar farm so I hope I'm
wrong and we don't see a significant
increase in the number of solar
applications across our district and
time will tell over the next 3 month six
month year but I am worried we'll see a
big increase because of the fact we now
have a green Council and we're seen as
an easy
target
uh Council
wi yeah I'd like to just cover off the
the green Council easy easy target b um
I'm very much in favor of this motion
but I think we need to see it in the
wider context and The Wider context is
that at the moment we've got about 15 GW
of solar power in the UK the
government's energy policy is to go to
70 GW by 2035 so that's government
policy you've got three possible
approaches to this problem one is you
ignore the target which we don't agree
agree with the second one is that you
build solar Farms all over the place and
that seems to be the strategy that we're
on at the moment our policy is we have
roof um we have Brownfield and we
supplement with soda Farms but we give
ourselves a lot more flexibility with
the solar Farms I just want to give you
some numbers to put this into context so
the CPR the countryside charity
commission a report is a really
interesting report about rooftop solar
and they looked at all the commercial
buildings in the UK just took the south
facing buildings ignored 75% in case
they're not suitable you've still got 25
GW of capacity on roofs in the UK at the
moment in Europe a lot of European
countries are passing legislation to
mandate putting rooftop solar in place
some of the states in southern Germany
already produce half the amount of solar
energy that we do in the UK just one
state in southern Germany if you look at
Brown downfield sites there's incentives
in a lot of European countries along
motorways Railways France has just
passed some legislation for car Parks
any car park with over 80 spaces within
5 years has got to have half of it with
a solar canopy over 400 spaces has got
to have the solar canopy within three
years so unless you do a lot more around
the roofs and the Brownfield sites we're
going to really struggle to stop this
wave coming at us
so I'm strongly in favor of this policy
but it needs to be and and we want to
see more renewable energy but we've got
to be more in more much more flexible in
how we how we approach this or we're
going to end up in a right
B thank you Cel Council
P yeah councelor winch has just
expressed um some some of what I was
going to say only far more
eloquently one concern that I do have
with the size of the solar Farms is that
they are capped deliberately at
49.9 megaw when they are clearly capable
of producing more energy is being
created that is just being
wasted um many of the ones
that declare themselves capacity at 49.9
megawatts are clearly there therefore
too large and do not need to be that
size otherwise declare themselves as
their true
capacity this is um some something I do
have concern
about but I will be supporting this
motion I think I might be the one
dissenting voice in the chamber because
unfortunately the policy statement is an
example of the types of tricky balancing
that comes with leaving it too late to
take take actions that are needed in the
climate emergency it would be much
better to already had had a planning
framework and infrastructure in place
already resulting in much greater solar
panel coverage on R Brownfield sites and
lowquality farmland because the INF
where there's infrastructure is also
partly what comes into where um
applications are being put in for and
while I understand the need for this
policy statement for us as a rural
District where the planning committee is
having to consider solar panel
developments and the sentiments of local
communities the policy statement for me
does not make clear enough the extent of
the crisis and the balance that may be
needed as the crisis continues to be
more apparent if we continue nationally
and internationally to fail to make
enough progress in minimizing the
effects of the climate crisis including
on our local communities and things like
um food supply
chains every time chair um so in my ward
we have Gateway 14 which as you know has
a massive field called the range which
has a roof or the range itself is one
1.2 million um Square fet which then
when you translate that up to the roof
which is actually um shaped it's
probably even bigger so you've got
approximately 27 Acres of space on top
of just the range itself which then at
625 kilow per acre you can generate
somewhere around 17 megawatt of energy
which we are currently not utilizing and
I know there are problems with
connections to the grid of getting that
energy out but energy comes in many
forms not just
electricity you can do a lot more with
the solar electricity than just keep it
as electricity you could have a solar to
hydrogen plant you could have a solar to
battery system you could perhaps
transport that energy to the residents
in in my ward um locally and you could
actually give them reduced bills so
perhaps we we shouldn't just think
narrow of what we can why are we
transporting all this energy out we
could actually change it to something
else and still generate it but I
definitely 100% think that every
building on Gateway 14 which we own
should be completely 100% solid and
think outside the box and do something
clever with that energy and not just
send it out to the grid thank you
Council have
we got to my contributions to the
debate
thank you Council mow would you like to
sum
up yeah thank you chair and I'm grateful
for all the different um perspectives
that have come into the debate can I
commend this position statement for what
it is uh and I realize its limitations
but it is a stepping stone to having a
full
SPD I hope it will provide some
assistance to our hardworking planning
committee as they work through these
difficult applications and decision
I absolutely understand the concern that
members are getting from their
communities and whilst it might be
affecting bramford and palgrave now it
I'm sure it will be my ward and yours
next um so uh I do share those concerns
and I'm sure they are coming to all of
us um as someone who's been involved in
in the food production industry and
still is to some small extent i' get the
concern we have about trading energy
production for food
production but I think uh as councelor
winch said we have this priority of
trying to get more solar panels on roofs
before we take up rural land and I would
love the government to mandate that um I
agree with Council ow that really we
we're not acknowledging the scale of the
emergency uh in one sense I wouldn't
have started from here if we'd been in
administration previously uh and had
agree in government we would have been
doing a lot more with solar panels and
other uh lowcost energy um
earlier just to just to um cover off the
the issue of the range um I understand
that 20% of the roof will be solar um
but we couldn't do more than that uh at
this time because of the the lack of a
connection into the grid due to um
someone else having a prior appointment
as it were with with National Grid um in
terms of a solar farm in that area but
the roof has been built strong enough to
take take more solar panels so I hope
that the business who is going to buy
the building off us will move to you
know 100% solar as my colleague uh
recommends and we should be exploring
those other ideas about you know turning
solar energy into hydrogen or other
forms so that we can use it or store it
or use it elsewhere but can I say that I
I would like uh councilors to vote for
this it's not perfect but it is kind of
where we are and um I commend it to the
council
thank you councel we have a second or
should we go
to a second unless the second wants to
speak would the second like to speak
now um Council Davis I'm more than happy
to Second this
coun I was asking if the second would
like to say
anything fine thank you then I'll now
ask the corporate manager governance and
Civic office uh to conduct conduct the
electronic vote thank you chair that is
showing in blue for members to cost
their
vote
councelor councel IND do you want to
place your vote
manually
um chair that is 29 votes for and one
against
so to
speak I'll continue then
um item 11 MC
2321 Community governance reviews 22 to
23 I would like to invite the inter
director law and governance and monitor
officer to introduce paper MC 2321
thank you chair and through you chair um
so the um the paper today is for the
council to be asked to approve draft
recommendations of the community
government's working group uh to go out
to wider consultation The Wider
consultation will include uh the
electors who live in the area that are
affected um MPS County counselors uh the
ward counselors uh and those town and
Parish councils again Ed they' those uh
bodies apart from the electors have
already been um as part of the initial
consultation but this time draft
recommendations and now be put before
them um so the
um uh in coming to the decision the um
Community governance working group uh
had a a site inspection on the 5th of
October and you can see the the
paperwork in the U uh that the plans and
the uh site inspection report is is
there to be seen um so what the
government working group is asking for
is that the uh recommendations at
appendix a issue one which is to do with
the boundary of Stone Market and uh one
house and issue two which is to do with
the boundary of uh bford and
Coes so um I would like to make one
correction to the report um at appendix
C it refers to councelor Miles row as
being Ward counselor Stone Market that's
incorrect and that the w should just be
deleted from that particular part of the
report um I would just say at this point
that these are draft recommendations and
all you're doing today is is putting
them out to
consultation uh that doesn't f any
future council meeting so this will come
back to uh a future council meeting in
January uh after the wider consultation
taken place and those um Rec those
consules and and their responses into
taken into account um the reason why
it's going out to The Wider consultation
is because the Electoral rangements and
boundaries for all four of those areas
are protected until 2027 so any
consultation needs to be wide enough for
the boundary commission to be able to
say well you've you've given a fair uh
consultation and for them to then accept
any decision that's made at the end of
the
day uh and chair any questions be
looking for a proposal in a second and
I'm happy to take any questions on the
report could I thank you H could I have
a proposal please Council
Manel um I'm happy to to um propose this
motion but um the interim manager for um
sorry if that's the right title um
whatever whatever the title is interim
interim director for Law and governance
has just quite quite categorically said
that this will be coming back to full
Council in January um but but item
number five on the
recommendations I don't think makes it
that clear that that is the case I'm
happy I'm happy to to propose it but
does item five actually need to say that
it will come back to council for who
make the final
decision it's a bit
out of a shall we answer that question
first CH yes that's absolutely the uh
the intention so uh the recommendation
should make that absolutely
clear so happy for that additional
wording to be put into
um well we could make an additional uh
recommendation
um at four at the end of four to say and
for the matter to come back to full
Council for a final
decision you want second could we have a
second
please councelor Lindon
yeah I'm very happy to Second this um
the group which I was part did three
meetings first on teams very well run by
if here and then we assembled on site
and we made most of a day thorough walk
around all these areas a b and c so we
could thoroughly assess the sense and
place and the impact it could make one
way or the other and after that we had a
second teams meeting where we cently
discussed all these matters once again
and we then unanimously decided
to go forward has so well put down on
this paper so I will be very pleased to
circum
this thank thank you councelor Council
scarf uh thank you chair if I understand
wrong rightly councilor Manel suggested
that this isn't clear that this comes
back to council I don't think by
amending recommendation for that does
the job because it still leaves five in
intact um I I would propose that
recommendation five be replaced with
that this item comes back to full
Council so a full decision by full
Council uh is is relevant um and I think
there are very good reasons for that
because I think our residents would
expect that such an important decision
would be decided by all counselors and
the issues of public trust and
transparency are the reasons I support
this amendment so if if I'm right I
think councilor Manel has proposed that
it comes back to
council I think by replacing item five
and I'm happy to second that chair thank
you need to need to get a second for
that am that's a new proposal then you
need to ask Council if she ACS right I I
I need to get a second now for Council
Scar's
proposal if there's a second
um Council
pearon thank you chair yes I'd like to
second that
proposal thank you councel and Council
Manel do you accept that I do but but I
think what we really need is is we need
um the uh officers to to read out what
items recommendations four and five are
going to be because I I agree look
looking at number four says Community
governance working group be authorized
to amend the draft recommendations and
go it to Recon reconsult item number
five then says the monitoring officer is
authorized to complete the CGR and I I I
I think I agree I think it should be
that after the decision has been made by
for Council the monitoring officer will
be authorized to go and make the
CGR I I think that's really what what we
want so I don't so maybe if the officers
can can actually tell me what we're what
the recommendations now say I think we
can then go forwards but I'm happy to
accept that because I think it is
important um certainly for that Stow
Market W us boundary that it is seen to
be a a full Council decision I think
it's very important for the residents of
that area I I agree Council I think
agress
would you like me to assist would you
please so chair just to assist um
Council so the actual amendment to to
recommendation five will be that the
item is brought back or the matter is
brought back to council for a final
decision by for Council and that the
monitoring officer be authorized to
complete the CGR and any required orders
once the all consultation submissions
are been considered by the community
governance working
group
coun and full Council and full council
at the end of that
yeah thank you very much I'm certainly
happy with that you're certainly happy
with that Council scar does that fit in
with your indeed I'm happy with that I
think it provides us with the clarity
that we need chair absolutely thank you
very so much um now uh we'll now move to
questions uh councils may ask as many
questions as wish however they must be
relevant to the subject under discussion
and must be a
question if if there are no questions
could I ask a question
coun uh could could you just outline who
the consult tees are going to be in
this yes chair the uh the further
consules will be the town and Parish
councils that have already been
consulted in the initial consultation uh
the electors in the area affected so
will be uh Stow Market one house
batsford and uh comes it will be the
county councilors and the ward
counselors for that particular area and
the MPS for those particular
areas thank you uh there is also u a
list of uh businesses in the areas but
um I'm little bit unclear as to whether
or not we can use that information under
data protection uh so there is a list of
businesses in the area those that can be
consulted and those whose details we
have will also be consulted as part of
the wider
consultation thank you Council M yeah um
can I ask
the you just said the the the areas
affected um but you also said the
parishes so is it in all the all the
residents of of the parishes and towns
affected or is it just the people that
are affected by the boundary being moved
on not
moved apologies no for clarity um all
15,000 electors in Stow Market the 871
electors in um uh one house bford the
figures are there I can't record them
off the top of my head um but so all
everybody that's so I I take back the
word affected it's those who live in
those those areas thank you Council
Carter I just want want to ask about the
method of how we are going to do the
consultation about uh with is is this
going to be electronic is it going to be
telephone is it going to be paper and
are we going to do a better job of
actually advertising it and promoting it
than we have done on
previous things that we're currently
doing at the
moment uh Council it will be through you
chair it will be a mixture um
we have uh some emails um on our
electoral register but those can only be
used for electoral purposes um so we're
very limited in in how we can use those
so the vast majority will be postage be
Letters Out uh we will also have a um an
email inbox so a dedicated email inbox
where once we advertise it through our
website and through the town and Parish
councils uh there will be a a dedicated
email inbox where um individuals can
respond directly so not just only by
post but through that means as
well Council
Walter thanks chair um so can I ask what
the minimum resp acceptable response
rate will be in terms of percentage of
the numbers that you outlay there and to
back up councelor Carter um can I also
ask that as well as all those methods
that you talked about to promote the
consultation that we also have an
element of outdoor media involved to
promote it to all the people that
otherwise won't see emails that won't
see or possibly receive letters Flyers
that sort of thing it's imperative in my
mind to have a successful conf
consultation you will need to have an
element of effective postering in
parishes town centers and
Wards um it it will will be advertised
on social media I don't quite know how
far that gets but it will be posted on
social media so I think it's the
Facebook page Etc um in regards to the
minimal response required there isn't
one um and a consultation you consult
the effective consultation is you spread
it as wide as you can through whatever
Med as you can um if the response is one
that's the response that that that
doesn't mean and then you take that one
response into
account would you like to continue I'll
come back to you Council C then yes
please counc um yeah sorry so social
media post isn't what I was referring to
what I'm asking is can the council
consider outdoor media of some
description for those people that don't
engage with online online social media
because there's there's far more than we
realize that do not see online emails um
social media Etc so I'm asking if you
will
consider posters physical posters being
placed across towns and
districts the answer to that is yes of
course yes of
course could I request that this be in a
number of formats left available so I'm
not talking about just writing but there
may be visual cited there may be to make
it as accessible as possible and have
these left in certain facilities either
Leisure facilities maybe doctors or
something that accessible where people
are going to go and may not have it is
an standard available format because we
have a number of residents here with a
number of difficulties and wanted to
make it as open as
possible
please thank you uh yes it's very
sensible are there any further questions
Council
W I might be the only person here who
doesn't know the answer to this and
apologies that's the case but I'm just a
bit confused where the council makes the
community governance order but then it
talks about the fact that everything's
sort of in concrete if you like until
June July 2027 with the boundaries
commission so how does that actually
work in terms of say the uh elections
for County in 25 and District elections
in
27 uh thank you chair that's why the
requirement for the lgbc
consent because those boundaries need to
be changed before 2027 because they are
protected at the moment
so so if it's approved by approved by
Council we then ask for that them for
their consent which they shouldn't
really withhold I guess yes if they do
withhold it then it doesn't happen the
order doesn't
happen are there any further
questions Council lawence yes excuse my
ignorance how do you balance the return
on consultation on the figures you've
just said whether there a potential
respons from 15,000 versus a potential
response from 800 how do you balance the
number of
repes chair through you it's a very very
good question but uh those are the
figures unfortunately those are the
people that live in those areas those
are the electors who are affected and
they are the ones who
are entitled to make a
response the
figures they're not weighted so you
wouldn't you wouldn't wait uh one area's
uh response to another area resp just
because of its size each one is a valid
response I think that's I think that's
all I can say from a consultation
perspective yes councelor coun Council
thank you um as a resident at one
house I'm really concerned about this
consultation and effective consultation
and Echo the thoughts of my colleagues
across the uh around digital
discrimination and knowing how many
elderly people Etc and people who aren't
on Facebook I'm really concerned that
there isn't any standards about um under
you know the numbers that we're looking
at back percentage wise of the
population yay nay or otherwise wise if
there is no response then it's you how
can you tell you've had an effective um
consultation I just feel that they ought
to be something set that says actually
if we're canvasing you know um 20,000
people then as a bare minimum 5% ought
to you know we ought to have some sort
of measure in place I'm just worried
that you do this work and you don't know
whether it's actually work been
effective and people have actually
understood it unless you're actually
measuring some sort of
response on I I think um that that's
sort of um needs a subjective answer I
the U if's already given an answer which
is that there's no limit on the the
number of responses there's no sort of
bottom line as it were um this is a
matter for consult going out to
consultation and this will be coming
back to full Council where we can look
at the responses the the nature of the
responses and possibly whether how the
consultation is been carried out so we
are looking at going moving forward to
the
consultation Council Hicks Just one
thought um there's an organization
called the consultation Institute which
gives good guidance on what is
considered to be a good and proper and a
thorough consultation and their guidance
is very clear I think if that's followed
then you can have some confidence in the
process thank you Council I
think I think we we are making I've been
advised that we're making we will make
thorough effort
to consult with every resident
business every stakeholder in all sorts
of different media in order to make this
process as accessible and transparent as
possible I
guess where are
we ' we've completed questions
um
poser
um we will now move to debate councilors
will only be allowed to speak once for
three minutes and this will be
timed SC Council
scar thank you chair um I'd like to make
a few observations as a district
counselor um currently Stone Market is
encircled by Green Fields and to the
north the A14 with these draft
recommendations this would no longer be
the case I think the importance of a
green buffer between the two communities
is really important and both parishes
have sought to protect that green buffer
between our communities for many years
that is a matter of fact how does this
proposal promote Community cohesion as
residents of both parishes will have no
Gap at all between them if the draft
recommendations are eventually uh
accepted I think one point I would like
to make is that it was only when pressed
by members uh of the district council
from Stone Market that the table papers
were amended to include appendix C which
is an absolutely vital element to
counselors making a fully inform formed
decision um I am certainly of the
opinion that these proposals in the
draft recommendations do not reflect
well on this Council and therefore I
would not support them thank
you
SC councilor
pet thank you chair um again I'd like to
um Echo councelor scaff's points and I I
also don't accept the recommendations
that we've seen in front of us um one
house and Stow Market are two
settlements that have been um separated
by around about 3/4 of a mile um and
they've been separated by what's known
as a strategic Gap discussing the actual
whether it should be going out to
consultation or
not well I'm I'm I'm obviously coming on
to this because I don't I don't agree
with um with
itations so I agree with that it should
go out to the consultation but there are
recommendations in here that that I
don't agree with and I feel that I
should explain expl why I don't agree
with those recommendations to my fellow
counselors is that
okay yes carry on so if if also there
there are some things in there that that
s don't really make sense if you look at
page 42 and 12.1 it says that there are
no environmental impacts well if you've
removed this strategic Green Space from
one house and Stow Market you've then
opened that land up it's fair game for
development so there are some nice um
flower Meadows there at the moment well
if we have removed this um line of
delineation between these two
settlements then it can be built on and
that has an environmental impact also if
we look at page 41 and seven and
sections seven and 8 Financial illegal
we're saying the only financial
implications are that it's some stamps
and some paper it literally says that
but if if we do not get if we do not get
get this through in the correct way and
there are disputes about these
boundaries is ongoing after we voted
about it we open ourselves up for a
judicial review from the other Parish
councils that is a financial implication
because that will cost tens perhaps even
hundreds of thousands of pounds to fight
a legal case against the parishes I'm
not saying it will happen it could
happen and that's that's not been
considered in this and I think the
people that live in Union Road when they
bought these houses they didn't think
they were buying a house in one house
they thought they were buy buying a
property in Stone Market this is quite
clear from the developers who are um
Hopkins homes mil Grove and I'd like to
read it to you please um milgrove is
being developed by Hopkins homes in
association with the Flav chick group
offering stylish new homes in a
delightful Market town of Stow Market
the people who built these houses and
bought these houses thought that they
were living in Stone Market if you go on
right move other property apps available
you will see if you look at houses all
the houses on Union Road they're all
listed as Stow Market the people who
live there the people who built it the
people who sold it all think they're in
Stow Market you've got roads where one
house is on uh one kind of council tax
Band on the same road another is is on a
different one how's that fair this is
clearly an extension of Stow market and
not an extension of one house thank
you
um I'd like to Echo uh the comments that
have been previously said um I was going
to say very similar um things to
councilor patchet um to save time for
all of us I'll reserve my right to talk
later about that if that is indeed the
case not
[Music]
tonight
Lon I get the impression
that the developer here might actually
have
preempted what we are supposed to do
here namely potentially change Parish
boundaries so I don't think we should be
forced or tied up by what developer has
put into the flashy roaches and also we
about green buffer zones I don't think
it really matters to people whether the
buffer zone is within one house or Stone
Market if you buy a new house closed to
the boundary the green areas will be
there regardless of that so therefore I
don't think this really Bears Too Much
importance chck can I just come in I'm
just a bit concerned that we're getting
into the debate on actually a
recommendation that hasn't come before
us at the moment so if we can just
concentrate on the recommendation to go
out to consultation and cancel Pat's
point the environmental impact is on the
cons the the cost of the consultation we
are not discussing any decision tonight
so therefore I don't want you all to
predetermine yourself by saying you're
for it or against it because we haven't
had that consultation so if we could
just focus really on the recommendations
that would be
great um I have concerns about the
recommendations for the
consultation because as has already been
mentioned and there's um accessibility
is a big issue and I don't think it
would make clear um all the
nuances that come with kind of where you
put the boundary for this development
like I understand they not going to the
debate of all that but um as been heard
there's a lot to it which I think the
cut I don't think is represented in what
we have in front of us and I worry about
the how much when it goes out to
consultation that would then be
understood by people reading
it
respond uh thank you chair um I I'd like
to commend the go um Community
government's working group um having
read the report and and the and the fact
that you did spend all that time walking
the boundary um and I think I think
you've done so far you've done a very
thorough job H and I I I I understand
that there are it's obviously quite an
emotive issue for for people on that
side of Stone Market but we're not
actually deciding where the boundar is
going to be now we're deciding whether
we're going to consult and I think we've
had assurances from our officers that
they will do their utmost to make sure
that as many people who are likely to be
affected are reached with this
consultation consultation is a
consultation people some people will
always respond other people you know
apathy rules we can't dictate whether
someone should respond or not um I I'm
I'm sort of assuming that the parish
councils and the Town Council are well
aware of of the fact that this is going
out to
consultation and and I very much expect
them to do their own little bit of
publicity for their own causes um and I
and I think that um somebody asked how
we're going to look at all these
consultations well I think the
governance review working group will
have their work cut out because if we do
get a lot of responses which is what
we're hoping uh they'll all have very
different views and and it'll be up to
you to come up with the recommendation
that that will'll then be able to debate
about whether the Hopkins homes
development should be in Stow Market or
one us we're not debating that now we're
debating whether it should go out to
consultation um and I think that is what
what we should be doing we all think
it's important we need to consult as
widely as we can we need to see what our
electorate want and then the governance
review working group will look at all of
those responses they will come back with
the recommendation which we've now been
assured is going to come back to this
Council and that is when we'll have the
debate about where we put that line on
the map and which house is in Stow
market and which house is in W us so
let's go and say yes to this
consultation and let as many people as
possible respond thank
you I thought we better move on rather
get
bit thank you I think you've got us back
on track are there any further points
anyone wishes to make I think we have
had summing up uh
Council yeah just a just a quick uh
comment um I I really support that we we
put this out to consultation as Ward
member for bford um I think that the
proposed changes are fairly
uncontroversial um at the moment uh B
corner is in the Parish of kums um it's
like an enclave but there isn't really a
direct road going to kums from that it
goes through little fimber before it
reaches kums so it' be great to return
this little Enclave well to to have this
Enclave really placed in bford and I'm
sure our residents you know this this
was bought up in 2018 so our residents
really really want us to get going on
this and they want us to consult so
thank you thank you very much for
that there are if there are no further
contributions I think I would just so we
are quite clear on what we're voting for
I'm just going to ask the governance
office to to read out the proposal
again thank
you so it's the last um recommendation
that we're changing um so on your vote
so on your voting you'll see that it
includes the amendment to recommendation
um five as discussed um and the that um
that the matter is brought back to full
Council for a full discuss disc and that
the monitoring officer be authorized to
prepare the draft recommendations for
consultation in accordance with the no
I'm on the wrong Amendment
sorry last two
yeah okay let me go back to the paper
sorry chair I CAU you both you
did yeah so the monitoring officer be
authorized to complete the CGR and any
required orders once all the
consultation submissions have been
considered by the community governance
working group but before that the bit is
that it will be brought back to full
councel um for um full decision by full
Council and we'll tidy up that wording
but that that is the
dis
thank you chair that is now going to be
showing in blue for counselors to cost
their
vote
councelor hardingham are you okay
or can I take your vote
then
okay
um chair that is 28 votes for and two
against uh
item 12 uh MC 2322 changes to the
Constitution I'd like to invite the
interim director law and governance and
monitor officer to introduce the paper
MC
2322 thank you chair and again through
you chair uh so the Constitution working
group looked at a number of uh
amendments and changes to the
Constitution uh one of the um uh changes
they wanted to put put into place was to
uh have more qualitative and inclusive
um language contained within the
Constitution so the changes are an
attempt to do that uh may not captured
every single one but that's the that's
the attempt um and in fact um further on
in the council standing orders the new
Council standing orders there is one uh
part of it that isn't doesn't have those
changes so I will endeavor to make sure
that that that happens in the new um
contract standing orders
um as the U Constitution was gone
through as well it turned out that lots
of the links weren't working they were
broken some of the links were old so all
these things will will now be sorted and
so next time you go on to your
Constitution um all the links will be
working and you'll get to the
appropriate page and they will be
updated
Etc um just just the the main point so
um the the um uh OB scrutiny
chair um the the U proposal is that it
be changed so the overan scrutiny chair
does not form part of the
administration
the uh licensing of regulated committees
and their subcommittees there was an
inconsistency in the um uh in the
Constitution at one point it said yes
you could substitute and another part it
said no you couldn't so that consistency
inconsistency has been taken out you
cannot substitute onto
licensing uh and Regulatory committee
and or the
subcommittee uh and the inclusion of
political assistance as well that's
that's also being cated for it's part of
the um that takes into account a
previous decision of this uh uh this
full Council to include political
assistance um there was deletion um of
the planning referral committee after
your annual Council uh in May in June
sorry you um deleted the referral
committee so this just makes sure that
that that's happened in the paperwork
and also the um development control uh
committee A and B and now no longer
there is just one planning committee uh
that planning committee has eight
members with four permanent substitutes
and that's the that's the that's the
difference chair unless unless there are
any questions I'm looking for a proposal
and a second and then I'll take any
questions in regards to any other word
could I have a proposal please coun
leave then
um thank you very much chair i' be very
happy to propose um this paper and these
recommendations and I uh appreciate the
particularly the more inclusive language
that we'll be using um throughout the
Constitution and I'd look to um one of
my colleagues to Second this um these
recommendations thank you
chair Council masteron would you like to
second that thank you chair yes it gives
me very great pleasure to to be able to
Second this um this set of changes to
the Constitution thank you thank you
Council M are there any
questions Council
cson thank you very much chair um in the
um in the boxes page
72 it simply says paragraph 7.1 needs to
be
rewarded I don't know if this is a
mistake it seems like if we're amending
the Constitution we need actual words we
can't say it needs to be
reworded
um page 66 of our
papers
CH I can read that out if that's helpful
to
everyone um page
66 it says page 72 paragraph 7.1 needs
to be rewarded and that's that's the
amendment that we've got for this and
it as far as I know I think we need
actual
words if we're amending
something
yes thank you for pointing that out
councelor it's uh it is this is just to
bring in more inclusive language so it's
not to change the substance of the of
the actual paragraph at all so there it
says his her that will be changed to
they that that's that's all that was
referring to um it doesn't
mention any of that it simply says
paragraph 7.1 needs to be reworded
exactly that that was the that was the
that that paragraph comes under the um
the opic of more inclusive language
there is no intention whatsoever to
change the tenor of 7.1 just to change
its inclusive language that's all and I
and I I'm quite happy it should be
amended to read at 7.1 to um remove uh
his her and replace with
day is
that well I I think it needs to say that
personally no that's exactly because
reworded it could it could be changed to
anything if we're amending it to be
reworded we need we need to know what
those words are and everything else in
here has got the exact words that will
be changed th those are the exact words
I'm proposing that's that's what should
go into that box against page
72 7.1 here we can we can I think we can
change yes we can change that we chose
that chair as a proposal I'd be happy
for those exact words to go in there at
that point to say it's being reworded to
ensure the language of his her has
changed to to them so as an amendment
that's been accepted would we're very
happy with that that's an answer to my
question thank you Council Mass
you Council M do you have a question no
no just
second I also AC those words thank you
very much Council
man um C can I just ask if if this um
use of inclusive language is going to
spread across the rest of all our
documents because I I happen to have
just noticed that we have an
inconsistency on mod. goov tonight in
our um agenda I think it's called the
Chairman's announcement but the actual
document is listed chair's announcement
so um can we have this um more inclusive
language um in all our documents not
just in the Constitution um so that
we're we're we're giving the right
message across everywhere thank you
chair three through you just to confirm
that that is in the process of being
looked at thank you thank
you have we got any further
questions
um unless there is a a real desire for a
debate I think we could actually go for
a vote is there a desire for debate on
this point changes the
Constitution then I propose going to the
vote uh and ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic
vote
um chair that is um now being amended to
um reflect the Amendments that councilor
Caston proposed so it's ready to vote
thank
you
chair that is 26 votes for and one
against and three
extensions thank you that is
carried uh I'm now moving on to item 13
I'd like to invite Council melon to
introduce paper MC 2323
and to move the recommendations in the
report thank you chair um this is uh
simply to uh put into into place the
timetable for the municipal year
2425 which is attached append appendix a
I don't think this is particularly
controversial so the recommendations are
that the draft committee timetable uh
for 2425 attached spendex a be approved
and the chief executive calls the
meetings in accordance with with the
green timetable unless there is
insufficient business for the meeting to
go ahead so I'm happy to propose that
thank you councilman Council um could I
have a second
please I'm thank you chair happy to
second that thank
you uh we now move to questions uh
before we begin questions i' would just
like to say that if there are any
questions regarding dates of specific
meetings I would like them to be taken
up please with the corporate manager for
governance Civic officer outside this
meeting otherwise we're going to be
going through every meeting and
discussing whether that's an appropriate
date or
not Council Hicks it's just a point of
principle we've just changed the
November meeting next month uh when we
set the dates a year ago and a lot of us
have put them in our diary booked
holidays booked other meetings around
those so can I just ask that if we vote
this through tonight we do stick to it
and not change it like we just did with
the November meeting a couple of weeks
ago I know myself and Council Stringer
will be away at a meeting that day and
you know we'd rather be here and be able
to attend every meeting so can we just
keep to these dates and not move them
please I think I concur with that
actually Council thank you Council
Manel I I I I completely Echo councilor
Hicks for once we agree um maybe not for
once maybe it's a sign of things to come
um uh I've got two points I'd like to
make um first one I think um may have
been brought up every year for the last
12 years that I've been a counselor is a
plea for a more electronic 21st century
version of the calendar I think someone
has asked that every time I've sat in a
council meeting discussing the uh
calendar so that's my first question it
would be wonderful if they could
automatically be put into our U
electronic calendars so that we don't
have to transfer them all manually and
make mistakes um and I'd also just like
to um ask a question about
recommendation
2.2 um which talks about the chief
executive um will call a meeting um and
and and every time a meeting is
cancelled or moved or
postponed it the message comes through
as in consultation with the chair uh and
yet that isn't in 2.2 and I just wonder
uh should it be there um or is it up to
the chief executive to decide whether we
go ahead with the meeting or not thank
you it should be done in consultation
but actually is the chief executive as
the proper officer who has the ability
to summons and call counselors to a
meeting and is there any any progress
towards the electronic 21st century
version of the calendar we do keep
trying counselor but the issue that we
have it's a firewall issue um and it's
the it um the suff county council's it
blocks the download of what we're trying
to do for modern. goov but we we have
got a a ticket in with modern. goov that
um if we ever get to a point where we go
to a cloudbased um system with them
which I which is actually coming up in
the future we we may well be able to do
that so we can look forward to our
Calendar's being fixed and in the
cloud um excuse my
frivolity um
are there any further questions
regarding this
item
uh sorry show
hands show hands if you want to we could
we could unless there is a real leak for
debate I think we could actually sort of
decide this by a show of hands if people
are happy to do so if you
already um if you already
agree with the motion could you please
show your
hands chair that's unanimous that's
unanimous that's carried thank
you um I would now like item
14 um I'd now like to invite isty Al to
introduce paper MC
2324 uh I'm just waiting
for Jan to leave the room this is the
appointment of an interim monitoring
office thank you thank you chair again
through you for the third time today um
so the the appointment of an inter
monitoring officer every council is
required to have a monitoring officer
it's a statutary role um along with the
head of paid service and and the
section1 officer and you're not allowed
to have any breaks in between you have
to have a monitoring officer at all
occasion uh as most of you know I'll be
leaving on the 31st of um uh of this
month uh so as from the 1 of October the
1 of November the the view is that uh
Janice Robinson who is the uh corporate
manager for Law and governance be
appointed the interim monitoring officer
as I said it's a statutory go it has to
be has you have to one um um a propos a
second please and and any questions um
if there are any questions with regards
to the role then uh Kathy Nixon will
will respond could have a
proposal
um Council M would
like yeah I'm happy to uh to propose
this chair Council
Lawrence Council e I'm happy to Second
thank you you
chair um are there any questions on this
appointment Council peon Lawrence
B thank you chair could I you're not
being rude but could you could somebody
explain what qualifications Jan has to
fulfill this role
please chair through you um Jan Robinson
has been the deputy monitoring officer
for quite some time and um so is used to
both carrying out that role and on
occasions the monitoring officer role
when
required um I I hope this is a an
allowed question I mean we we're here
voting about an interim uh mon officer
and we're all very sorry that that um FC
Al is is departing next week um can I
just um ask whether we've already made
moves to find a permanent replacement um
and and and what stage we're at with
that thank
you um so I can confirm that the job
advert has closed and um we are at the
stage where technical interviews are
taking place next week and we expect to
be at final interview in the middle of
November thank you
Jesse are there any further
questions just my my pleas right here we
go uh could we now go to debate
is matter for debate kelse
kton um I just just like to take this
opportunity to thank ify for everything
he's done I was some chairman when he
came in and he's fantastic at his job
and he's a really nice person to be in a
meeting with And discussing things and
um thank you very much for what you've
done and enjoy your
[Applause]
retirement could we
move
electronic
vote thank you council is uh that vote
is now in blue for you to vote on the
app
I would just like to ask Will there be
somebody appointed as an interim to
replace Janice's position as Deputy as
well now um the corporate manager for
audit will um take on the role of Deputy
monitoring officer whil Jan steps
up thank you chair that vote is 30 votes
for she
that's um but someone like to bring Jan
back
in
[Applause]
was a no
J thank you
congratulations thank you uh we now move
to item 15 Council appointments I would
like a proposal please to appoint a
sustainable integrated transport work
group and the nominations for counselors
as table please for clarification the
membership is as follows councilor Keith
scarf councel Jilly Morgan councel David
Penner Council Sarah Manel Council miles
row Council James padet Cabinet member
Theresa
Davis and could I have a proposal
please Council
Davis um thank you chair
um okay so the area of sustainable
transport is very large and as you will
know includes trains buses cycling
walking the work is involved both vast
and detailed um we have only one officer
for both mids suffk and Baba and we the
green party feel this issue needs much
more focus and investment to meet our
residents needs um counselors have
offered their time and skills to assess
to assist our sustain sustainable
transport officer and therefore I would
like to propose we establish a
sustainable integrated transport working
group do we have a second please Council
melon yeah happy to Second this chair
and this is an important area of work um
but we'd like to move forward on a cross
party basis and um I think these the
names here will um will be able to
complement the work of our our offices
uh and support the cabinet member uh in
this area of
work okay I think I can move I'm going
to move straight to the vote now uh the
vote is to agree the appointments as
detailed I'll now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair it is showing in blue for you to
cost your
vote
councelor Carter um would you like to
place your vote
manually I should have gone
through thank you that is unanimous
chair thank you thank you that is
carried um do we have any motions on
notice no
chair I'd like to thank everybody for
quite a complicated evening the next
meeting is on Monday the 20th of
November at 5:30 p.m. in the council
chamber